[Música]
[Aplausos]
trajeron traje de baño
hoy los invito a nada conmigo quiero
participar con ustedes nada que de
alguna manera ha tenido mucho
significado en mi vida y no solamente
participar sino invitarlos a que juntos
aunque cada uno de ustedes puedan
participar y pueda llevar a cabo en el
lado rojo el lado de molokai que de
alguna manera tiene ese significado
no lo hagáis es una bisagra más conocida
como el contrario dejaba atrás aquella
isla que llevaba a todas las personas
que tenían toda la letra pero
posteriormente aquellas personas que
estaban enfermas
aquellas personas querían alguna forma
no tenía esperanza de vida
en el lado del blog hay se hace de esta
isla a la isla forma y guapo significa
vida petición y algunas que no quiere
nadar cada uno de los días de su vida
hacia la vida la bendición y aún así el
día de hoy los invito a es que todos
podamos verdad cada día de nuestra vida
hacia esa lámina en la bendición y
lagunas
y el nuevo empieza en una tabla en una
tarde como la de hoy en una tarde con
una luz especial con un
un mar con un color azul espectacular
[Música]
con munición con muchos sueños en mi
mente de saber que voy a dejar atrás
todo aquello que significa molokai es
vivir todo aquello que puede significar
tristeza deterioro enfermedad
muerte para nadar hacia la vida la
bendición y rondas
con esta maravillosa
pues así de alguna forma empezamos a dar
brazadas y muy pronto caigamos
y logran ver a dónde
viene a la mente aquello que nos
atemoriza
que nos dé una norma nos quita
concentración que nos hace pensar que no
vamos a poder llegar a nuestro objetivo
se nada toda la noche y durante la noche
bien no solamente a la mente aquellas
cosas que de alguna forma nos podrían
hacer
desviamos el objetivo también vienen
estas criaturas físicas que se llaman
aguamalas que pican típica muy fuerte y
no las ves y te molesta y cada vez que
te pica una tienes un actor muy
especial y vas nadando durante toda la
noche está guiada únicamente por una
pequeña luz por el faro de ese faro
el punto hacia dónde va el punto de
nuestras vidas
el punto hacia la vida de bendición y la
abundancia
y cuando finalmente amanece después de
nadar toda la noche 12 horas después
también empezando a esperado
yo pienso que ya que lo más complicado
ya voy a poder en un momento dado
en punto determinado que de alguna forma
ya no está mareada durante la noche
estuve muy mareada lo único que podía
ver con un punto fijo era aquella
lucecita del fango que se prende y se
apagaba el callar que venía
acompañándome en a mi lado me generaba
movimiento estaba en movimiento
constante las luces titilar invisibles
me mareaba
cuando amanece dije ya pasó la pelota el
maxi de tirado el más sigue siendo
porque es el mar el cielo maravilloso
pero al menos ese amanecer me indica que
estoy cada vez más cerca del objetivo
incluso puedo ver la isla puedo ver esta
isla guaje que sin mis calidad de visión
y algunas en un mirador es a ella
no tengo a mi lista me seca y
probablemente me tardé en llegar unas
tres programas
cuando aparecen los primeros rayos de
sol durante este amanecer escuchó un
grito maría maría un tiburón
y entonces la película de mi vida pasa
en mi mente
my el título es una frase
que hoy con ustedes y que en el momento
que escuché quise caminar son realizados
salirme de ese punto deslizado y dejar
atrás todo lo que estaba
en ese momento
y cuando el kayakista me pregunta qué
pasa porque no se sabe por qué
y la respuesta del callo risa me dice no
te distraigas y sigue ganando
como no te distraigas y sigue nadando si
hay un tiburón aquí abajo
no te entregas
y yo creo que es algo que puedo
compartir con ustedes para todos los
colores que a través de su vida no se
distraen y siga ganando
sin embargo la película de mi vida
estaba en ese momento haciendo su efecto
en donde estoy qué significado tiene
siete más alejada de la mancha la página
de intento para nada
[Música]
donde estoy nadando el canal y resaltan
algunos lados por completar los siete
más me falta el canal de enorme muestra
para jugar me falta el 6 ritmo y qué
pasa ese título que pasó por debajo de
libia
qurius yo era un tiburón cero y hoy se
conceda es curioso cazador y solitario y
de alguna manera estaba curiosa su
curiosidad casi me saca del agua
también ese seguro mismo
[Música]
y tener sobre todo muy claro una parte
que había sido el motivo por el cual
estaban los trabajos una caída una
realidad muy profunda de dónde vengo
porque estoy nadando sawan porque quiero
nadar hacia la vida a la rendición y de
auténtica
porque hace unos años hace un par de
años había intentado nadar en japón
y después de todas las tormentas del
pasado y mi vida
después de estas tormentas emocionales
que de alguna forma es tenido que
alcanzar
en donde tengo dos fallecimientos muy
próximos
aparte
físicamente en japón en toda una
tormenta una tormenta nada cuando voy
nadando
lo que estoy en medio de una tormenta
porque le tomó una tormenta estoy
enojada traje
muchas
tengo una parte de mí que está muy muy
enojada porque me tiene que tocar una
tormenta para jamás
y cuando recibo la indicación de la
embarcación que debo de tener minado y
subir de la nación
porque no puedo
veríamos
por éstas
y en un mundo mi autoridad me dice no
puedes llenar te tienes que subir a la
embarcación
no vas a llegar a ningún lado
y estoy con este enojo con este coraje y
le sino que un par de pasadas más
un par de brazadas en que en ese momento
su médico mi cabeza
y el fondo del mar más
mujeres que aquí arriba está la peor
tormenta mucho viento mucho oleaje no
importa y cuando es un mismo mi cabeza
y finalmente reciba la lancha
como la embarcación no hay opción no se
puede seguirla
verán
me fue
me caigo porque me doy cuenta que en
esta ocasión como en todas las ocasiones
previas de la vida las tormentas
lo que tienen que hacer
igual
cuando pasa la tormenta que
probablemente a veces ni siquiera somos
conscientes de que las 2000
me agrada que soy distinta
esa tormenta me gusta decir que esa
promesa de creación que a través de la
tormenta
puede seguir dando pasos en frente
puede levantar puede decir yo sigo
adelante
y esa tormenta es lo que me permitió
poderme levantar y decir
sigo
cuando tengas una caída cuando vayas por
una tormenta
no dejéis que la gravedad
o que la tormenta hagan efecto de
destruirle sino de fortalecer levantan y
levantan de pronto levántate
con un objetivo claro a dónde vas
y para que una vez que dé su paso al
frente
uno más y así hasta llegar a todos tus
objetivos a todos sus propósitos
y una vez que me decido
a la mitad del lado de molokai con un
tiburón que está nadando debajo de mí
como un título cuando yo asumía que ya
había pasado lo peor
y recuerdo la frase que me dice el
genetista
no te distraigas y sigas sigue lavando
no permitas este tipo de sus objetivos
yo comparto con ustedes creo que los
peores tiburones no están en el habla
que están fuera del agua y los más
complicados tiburones
en nuestra mente
y nos frenan los panalistas nos
atemorizan cada día
y la cuenta que tenemos con los tres
humanos de hacerlos a un lado
y de continuar con nuestros objetivos
esto no es el camino
es un privilegio
es un privilegio que podamos como seres
humanos concientizarlos de los problemas
que tenemos pero también de poder
decidir sabiendo
decididos adelante de seguir caminar o
de seguir nadando
que ningún tiburón te distraiga de tus
sueños sino que te conduzcan ahí
siempre
y seguimos nadando seguir nadando para
salir del agua
después de 14 horas con 28 minutos
y comparto con ustedes es nada malo que
hoy comparto y además de alguna manera
es suministración para que todos
nosotros podamos andar hacia eso hacia
lo que significaba local
la vida está bendición y aún más porque
cada uno de nosotros tenemos sobre
nuestra cabeza todas las bendiciones del
universo y lo único que tenemos que
hacer es decir son mías
y yo adquiero todas estas bendiciones
[Música]
todo lo que significa lo mejor de su
vida que está en ti
y cualquier cantidad que puedas tener
levántate y bastante pronto
sigue dando pasos
donde los objetivos y los sueños más
grandes que puedas imaginar y alguien te
diga es una locura lo que estás pensando
aunque sea una altura antes de firme
porque la capacidad que tenemos de ser
conscientes de ese sueño se puede hacer
realidad es el primer paso para hacerlo
realidad y una vez que haces ese sueño
realidad tendrás muchos más
y entonces podemos decir que ningún
tiburón me distrajo en sueños y que
además de todas las tormentas por las
que tuve que atravesar xavi diferente
fortalecido
y hoy
como es el fondo del mar que como yo iba
nadando y estaba la tormenta de arriba y
sin embargo el fondo de la lista de paz
deseo que cada uno de ustedes tengo un
corazón como el corazón del mar
que siempre esté paz no importa que
también estás descentralizado no importa
qué tormenta es atravesar
pero que el corazón siempre se pase
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]